viking's valhalla has finally arrived
and it's packed with parallels to its
predecessor what's up with yarl's rune
why is that chain so familiar answers
straight ahead
category was just a small port town when
we first saw it in vikings but the
former seat of ragnar lothbrok has grown
into a bustling multicultural center of
trade by the time viking's valhalla
begins spreading from the shore of the
fjord right up into the valley beyond it
is
more beautiful than i ever imagined it's
a free city and the center of the viking
world in norway and as such it needs to
be protected the location comes with
natural defenses notably the narrow
entryway makes it difficult for a fleet
of invading ships to enter it's better
to be safe than sorry however which is
why there is a new addition to the port
that was apparently inspired by ragnar's
greatest defeat ragnar's raid of paris
was one of the standout moments on
vikings he fakes his death and enters
the city in a coffin having undergone a
sham conversion prior to his staged
passing but when he returns to the
frankish capital a second time he is
outsmarted by a thick chain that the
franks had installed across the river's
seine hidden below the surface when the
viking fleet gets close the franks pull
the chain up and cause a mass pileup
sinking many ships and repelling the
invading force perhaps inspired by that
very moment category now uses a similar
device in its harbor making doubly sure
that unwelcome ships cannot dock
the chain device that foiled ragnar and
company when they returned to frank kia
was the brainchild of rollo the first
duke of normandy and ragnar's brother
overlooked and underappreciated roller
decides to switch sides when the franks
come to him with an offer defend paris
from further viking attacks and he would
be made a rich man he is given land
which would become known as normandy and
offered the hand of princess gizla
daughter of the emperor charles ii it's
an uneasy union to begin with but gizla
comes to trust and even love her viking
husband after he saves her beloved city
from his own kind in viking's valhalla
king ethored of england is married to a
norman woman queen emma when he dies the
defense of england is left to emma and
she's forced to channel her inner viking
as a member of her court remarks in a
throwaway line that she might have
missed who bettered to defend england
from the vikings and the
great-granddaughter of rolo himself
i will deal with that
there are many parallels between the two
as emma points out she was a stranger to
england when she arrived but was able to
master the language and gain the trust
of the people rollo would no doubt be
proud of his great granddaughter who
proves herself to be a real survivor
over the course of the first season
prince harold sigurdsson reveals early
on in vikings valhalla that he is the
great grandson of a man known as harold
feinheir that name will probably mean
nothing to if you've joined the party
with vikings valhalla but those who
watched vikings will know that harold
feinheir was a viking king who defied
the odds to become king of all norway he
believed that it was his destiny to rule
over his homeland and it put him at odds
with ragnar and his sons at times in
prince harold's case his ambitions pit
him against his half-brother king olaf
all of haroldson has promised prince
harold that the throne of norway will go
to him upon his death but what he
doesn't tell him is that he's had a son
in secret according to king canute of
denmark olaf plans to have his son take
over after he's gone cutting harold out
of the picture if harold joins forces
with knut on his quest to create a great
northern empire he will guarantee him
the norwegian crown will harold
eventually achieve his dream just like
his great grandfather did that will no
doubt be addressed in the coming seasons
of vikings valhalla but those of you who
are up on your viking history will know
that harold sigurdsson became known as
harold harada meaning harold hard ruler
there are big things to come for leo
suter's character
while harold sigurdsson and olaf
haroldson are christian vikings though
the latter is far more stern in his
beliefs with little patience for the old
pagan ways however he pales in
comparison to yaral korra a zealot who
wants to wipe away the old gods
completely he's absolutely ruthless when
it comes to spreading the word of jesus
christ really murdering any pagans he
comes across when we see his backstory
the reasons where his warped worldview
become crystal clear korra was brought
up pagan and as a child he witnessed his
brother die as a human sacrifice to the
gods korar wears gloves most of the time
and when he returns to uppsala we
realize that he's been covering up his
past quite literally he gains entry to
the temple by showing the guard a
y-shaped symbol tattooed on the palm of
his hand the symbol is known as augus
the ancient norse rune of protection
it's been seen many times in the vikings
universe it was one of the runestones
that ubba and torvi left for the native
north americans as gifts upon arriving
in the so-called golden land
when jaral kora returns to uppsala
posing as a pagan he heads straight to
the altar where his brother had his
throat cut to appease the gods and
proceeds to carve his algae's tattoo out
of his palm it's a brutal scene but it's
nothing compared to what he has planned
for the priests of the holy pagan site
after talking to the seer once more the
yarl and his berserkers go on a rampage
slaughtering everyone at uppsala and
burning the prize temple to the ground
koran his men leave a few kids alive but
not out of mercy they want them to tell
the pagans of cataget that they're next
that's not quite enough to prove his
point so korra takes a page out of
ragnar's playbook to really scare his
enemies he beheads the priests and
attaches their severed heads to a boat
which he sends floating toward category
ragnar uses this very tactic while
trying to terrify the mercians over in
england and it works very well still
kora knows the people of catagette are a
tough breed so for good measure he
crucifies the head priest nailing her to
the mast of the ship
when we return to catagets and vikings
valhalla it's being ruled by yarl hokan
a pagan viking of african descent she
reveals to freitas eric's daughter that
she had dreams in which the water next
to category recedes into the ocean
revealing a bounty of fish the people
believe it to be a blessing from the
gods but when the water returns it
causes widespread death and destruction
of course it's the tsunami that hokan
has dreamed of and one that was
foreshadowed long ago in season 4 of
vikings the opening credits sequence of
vikings has always used the song if i
had a heart by the swedish
singer-songwriter fever-ray though the
imagery was tweaked and updated from
season to season in season four's
opening credits a brief shot shows the
tsunami wiping out cataget but it
doesn't come from the sea it comes from
the direction of the valley how can a
tsunami come from inland as vikings
valhalla season 1 nears its end koran
olaf launched their assault on katagat
they trick koken and her allies into
thinking they will use the high tide
provided by the wolf moon to attack from
the sea when in fact they plan to come
from the other side throwing a wave of
christian warriors at the city
while planning his attack olaf remarks
the walls of cardigan have not been
breached in over 100 years it's a
throwaway comment about a bygone era to
many of his men but those who watched
vikings will know exactly what he's
talking about the category civil war was
one of the major events in the first
series fought between the sons of ragnar
lagertha decides to pounce when they are
away from cataget overthrowing queen
ozlog being lagertha's son bjorn takes
her side while oslog's sons want revenge
forces led by ivar the boneless assault
category but are defeated after calling
in a favor from his uncle rolo now a
powerful man in francia ivar's forces
return and with the help of a thousand
frankish soldiers the invading army
forces lager though to flee ivar takes
power but he seals his own downfall by
proclaiming himself a god and turning
those closest to him against him the
walls of catagets are only fully
breached by bjorn and company because
ivar's wife freitas secretly opens a
gate and lets them in a century later
olaf manages to do it by force but he
has to flee within minutes of his great
victory having secured his son's fleet
canoe's father swain forkbeard arrives
to deal with the men he deems traitors
what is left of olaf's army flees hit
the side of his banners and he's not far
behind them
when king knut of denmark decides to
stay in england and rule the country it
surprises vikings and saxons alike he
needs the wealth of england to make his
great northern empire a reality which is
why he decides to keep edmund the
recently crowned replacement for the
late king aethelred as a puppet to
control the problematic english nobles
but before he gets to politics he needs
to know that all 11 nobles are serious
about their commitment to him so he has
11 gallows erected he then sends earl
godwin to fetch the nobles who have been
locked away the defiant noble from north
umberland can be seen fiddling with his
fancy rings as he insults godwin which
is a big mistake godwin invites him to
go up and see the new king first when
the other nobles follow one of the
gallows is used to kill their
counterpart from northumberland canoe
proceeds to give the remaining nobles a
choice and as he addresses them he can
be seen holding something shiny in his
hands it's clearly one of the rings that
the noble from northumberland wore so
proudly he may be the new king of
england but he's still a viking at heart
leif eriksen is one of the most famous
vikings of all time credited with
establishing a settlement in north
america some 500 years before
christopher columbus arrived in the new
world at the beginning of viking's
valhalla however late still lives in the
considerable shadow of his father eric
the red is a notorious murderer who is
banished from norway and then from
iceland for his crimes forcing him to
make a home on greenland when life
arrives at catagets with his sister
freitas eric's daughter and a crew of
greenlanders he's recognized as the son
of a dishonorable man he's even attacked
for it but he proves that he's not a
killer by sparing the men who tried to
take his life
you're just like your father
you're wrong
if i was like my father you would all be
dead leif later reveals that the same
darkness that drove his father lives in
him too and that he only feels calm and
content when he's with fellow
greenlander live the pair form a
romantic relationship as part of king
knuts army becoming closer still after
their comrades from the north fall in
battle when liv is killed the darkness
that lape spoke of comes to the surface
the greenlander becomes his infamous
father and he kills so many men in his
rage that he's literally red his chest
and torso covered in blood
when the viking army arrives in england
to avenge the slaughter of their people
and the saint price's day massacre they
have to figure out how best to attack
london they decide to follow the advice
of king olaf and attempt to approach
london through the marshlands thought
impassable by many their approach is
anticipated however and the scouting
party is ambushed some of life's friends
are killed and he's presumed dead as he
appears to be slipping away he opens his
eyes to see a little local girl looking
down on him she places a cross in his
hand lafe survives and he can't help but
wonder if the cross had something to do
with it when liv takes an arrow in the
shoulder and her chances of pulling
through seems slim he secretly leaves
the cross with her she also survives
there are several little moments that
hint at late moving away from pagan
beliefs and embracing christianity some
more subtle than others when yarohokan
sanctions a human sacrifice as they
prepare to defend cataget others watch
in awe as the volunteer is killed while
the look on late space suggests that
he's uncomfortable at best ragnar
flirted with christianity during his
lifetime and it appears as though lake
will do the same
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite television shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you